Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
we got to see Patton Oswalt and Adrian Pasdar
on Agents of SHIELD, Garrett and Ward raided
the Fridge and learned a lot more about the
TAHITI project.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Agents of SHIELD and bonus Marvel videos
every tuesday, be sure to subscribe to get
everything.
My bonus video tonight is X-Men Days of Future
Past and the Apocalypse movie that’s coming
next.
Tonight’s episode was so awesome let’s
just get into it.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Here’s my top 5 moments.
Number 5 - Garrett breaks Raina out of Prison
so she can resume Project Centipede
The whole goal of the project was to make
super soldiers.
Phase 3 is basically them trying to eliminate
the threat of death.
So their soldiers won’t ever die.
There’s also a lot of tech involved and
Garrett revealed that some of his more emotional
mistakes in the past led to his cyborg parts.
That’s right, they paid major homage to
the comic book version of his character, who
had a bunch of his human body parts replaced
with cyborg parts.
Just like Mike Peterson getting turned into
Deathlok.
Garrett’s cyborg parts on the show are just
less visible.
But I wonder what kind of upgrades he’s
had?
Did anyone else get the vibe that Raina might
turn on Garrett at some point?
Like she’s going to be so mad that he’s
not what he claimed to be.
She’s all about making the world better,
or whatever her idea of better is.
And I think she sees that Garrett doesn’t
care about making anything better.
He seems more like a thug.
Keep your eyes on her.
She might end up turning on HYDRA before the
finale.
Number 4 - Ward Is Everyone’s Type
This was so much fun.
Not only was there some Ward Raina ‘shipping,
he also revealed how he got everyone on Coulson’s
team to trust him.
First he jumped out of the plane back in episode
6, but he started having sex with May to throw
her off the scent.
And all he had to do to fool Coulson was play
hard to get.
So funny.
The promo for the next episode kind of spoiled
that Skye finds out he’s a double agent
and Patton Oswalt made that huge speech to
Coulson about vetting everyone.
I still think by the end of the Season he’ll
be back on Team Coulson.
He kind of explained his backstory a little,
his real backstory.
He said Garrett pulled him out of a terrible
situation.
I think we’ll find out what that is and
because of the relationship he formed with
Garrett over the years, I kind of think he
got a little brainwashed.
I think he’ll turn against Garrett eventually
and when he comes back to Team Coulson, he
and Skye will be just like May and Coulson.
Team mates, but not friends.
Also, don’t you feel like Skye seems to
gravitate towards all the worst dudes.
Like if I wanted to get her to go out with
me, I should join HYDRA and be evil and it
would just dramatically increase my chances
with her.
Speaking of gravity, Number 3 - Garrett and
Ward pull Gravitonium out of the Fridge
The comedy of this situation is that we as
the audience know that the Gravitonium fused
with Franklin Hall back in episode 3.
I think that whenever they let it out of that
box it will just cause chaos for everyone.
Graviton was a villain in the comic books,
but that doesn’t necessarily mean he’ll
align himself with HYDRA and Garrett.
He might just try to destroy both Garrett
and Coulson because of what happened to him.
That’s the funny thing, it always seemed
like when classic comic book heroes got super
powers because of some freak accident, they
were really excited about it.
And when villains got dosed with radiation
or something else, they always sought revenge.
In fairness, most of the villains probably
only became evil as a result of the accidents
that gave them powers.
Number 2 - Garrett and Ward Raid The Fridge
I actually thought this was more fun than
the Graviton reveal at the end.
How funny was it that The Fridge is actually
on a beach?
They were like kids in a candy store.
And that scene where Garrett tells Ward all
about project slingshot was so funny.
“If it looks dangerous good, if it looks
alien great.”
My biggest question after all that was what
happened to all the monkeys they shot into
space?
and my number 1 moment - Patton Oswalt becomes
an Agent Of SHIELD
I felt like he had the perfect introduction
on screen.That total nerd moment he has when
he’s over explaining why the base has no
name.
They really took it to the Nth degree with
the nerdy basement metaphor.
As if he’s been holed up looking at porn
and playing video games by himself in an underground
bunker since The Avengers.
I’m glad to see he’s coming back in next
week’s episode and I really want to see
how he’s going to handle HYDRA Ward after
they find out he’s trying to get the data
on the hard drive.
But let me know what you’re favorite moment
was, raiding The Fridge?
Raina and Garrett just dosing everyone with
mysterious blue vials of alien blood or just
evil Ward in general?
Here are couple of the bigger comic book references
I spotted in no particular order.
There was the news report at the beginning
talking about all the leaked documents that
Black Widow released during Winter Soldier.
Garrett also gave her a nice shoutout when
he was complimenting Ward for infiltrating
Coulson’s team.
The Barber Chair to the Secret Hydra base
feels like a big reference to Spies Like Us.
When Coulson’s team talks about The Cube
being retaken, they’re talking about a Black
Site like TAHITI from the comics.
For a while it was used as a prison for aliens.
I guess you could say that blue alien in TAHITI
was also in a prison of sorts.
When we see Glenn Talbot it’s a huge reference
to the Hulk comics.
He worked under General Ross, so you can imagine
how he’s going to deal with threats.
Generally someone to avoid at all costs.
And the most fun one was the Griffin reference.
Garrett talks about the person they arrested
that had lion’s paws for hands.
In the comics he was a normal person who had
surgery to make him look more like a mythical
griffin and also got dosed with a mutagenic
serum.
Let me know if you saw any other references
I didn’t mention in the video.
Overall I gave the episode a solid A, one
of the best this season.
I think the HYDRA SHIELD in chaos plot has
really added this sense of urgency the show
hasn’t had.
Like a ticking time bomb is still waiting
to go off.
I love what they did with Ward’s character.
Now we know why his performance was so wooden.
I really did not dig the Boy Scout aspect
of his character.
It was like he was basing his double agent
performance based on how he thought Captain
America would act in similar situations.
Which is kind of funny when you think about
it.
Patton Oswalt is a giant leap forward in guest
actors, he’s so perfect for the character
he’s playing.
I got this meta Star Wars flashback when that
turret popped up and fired.
Like they were on Hoth and it was the Probe
Droid Han Solo and Chewie run into.
Which just made me think about Patton Oswalt’s
filibuster pitch for the plot of Episode 7.
I’m really looking forward to the addition
of Graviton into the mix with Deathlok, Team
Garrett and Team Coulson all vying for what’s
left of SHIELD.
I’m also kind of wondering if Coulson’s
team are going to be the one’s to rebuild
SHIELD eventually.
Supposedly by the time the Avengers fight
Ultron next year SHIELD will still be out
of commission.
But Coulson seemed so adamant about upholding
the virtues of SHIELD.
I did get pretty excited when he did that
big Agents Of Nothing Speech.
Let me know what you’re final thoughts are
about the episode, and let me know what you
think is going to happen to Ward at the end
of the season.
In case you missed it I just posted a breakdown
of the new X-Men Trailer you can watching
it by clicking here and you can check out
my Arrow Season 2 finale predictions here.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight!